what would my next three to five moves
be combined with learning how to swim
with the river
i'm gonna leave and get some water
because i've been talking way too much
i'll be right back and i want to see
what kind of plan you might come up with
with that okay
okay all right got it got it
oh my god this is this is a lot
[Music]
got a minute come on veggie oh and he's
not streaming so we can't see oh
oh no it's gonna be this exact checkmate
it's gonna be the checkmate
here it comes starter sees it no
question he's good
to do this mate oh boy
oh boy oh oh queen oh my
gosh oh my gosh you blunted the queen
does benji see it does benji see it
benji do you see this oh he has to see
it look at benji's face he's in shock
oh he took the queen and sardosh loses
the queen
benji is so confused he's smiling
no the tragedy not the queen
[Music]
oh my god benji is smiling sardoch is
melting
he's melting oh no
sartosh played a great game he was
playing
so well and on one turn
doesn't see the queen on the outside the
board full board awareness
needs to see these things and
unfortunately for sodos queen
he is laughing at himself he is laughing
at himself
at least he's not crying well it's a
boates gambit for the ages
and benji fishy wins the group
i just got a shot into bobby hall's
outfit
he's just like oh wow it's
not that looks like something right out
of the 1970s but he's dressed like
dwight from the office
true that's true i literally literally
have the yellow tie mug right here and
he
exactly bobby texted me last night and
said wait till you see my
outfit but i had no idea this was what
he was going to do this is hilarious
oh my god yeah defending he's slow
actual dog water take
attacking
can you guys take me off can you take me
outside.com
can you take me off the website
take me off the website get me off
congratulations you are making it to the
semifinals
critical oh oh
uh are you are you inspired
rain by critical's hair
yeah that's probably what that is yeah
i'm the new
i am the new chest jesus
you know
unbelievable sexy what a roller coaster
oh wait she's hovering over there ah
why does she want to eat
[Music]
no
[Music]
that's
yes yes six zero
undefeated yes baby
get it boys
[Music]
10 minutes it's over boom it goes here
that was not over oh it's over
now maybe we should take a look at
tubble let's see what he's thinking
since he
finally has the upper hand in this game
um
he has to be a little bit careful though
because his night is under attack
don't be scared
i think he's giving himself a pep talk
but you don't have that much time
how's your chest beyond that like how
much chest have you played because you
were amazing i mean we don't know much
about you so
i'm amazing and i i started playing like
three months ago or something like that
like and it was also
not because of queen's gambit but it was
uh because the
the previous spoke times where xqc
failed in six moves
after that i began watching more
more test streams and it was thanks to
xqc and hikaru so yeah
sweet i don't remember that six moves
i don't know what you're talking about
it's just looking still at the computer
he feels the pressure
oh no his queen is going to be trapped
after the knight moves
even 92 a simple move like that the
queen cannot move
uh if ludwig sees it i think this is his
game
and he sees it this is brutal
that will be a pinned queen and there is
actually no way for black to get out of
that pin
he should cry oh i didn't even notice it
was a pin
whoops yeah even after bishop takes f3
you can play queen
not the best move but i mean again oh
queen takes what we take queen what
she doesn't even see it she's only
looking at her rook under attack
oh oh she i think she spotted it she
took
she took its game on oh
what happened see i told you michelle
[Music]
oh no oh no oh no
queen f2 logic misses it queen of two
oh no oh we missed it
and now he's right because me ludwig has
a force made in two
and now he's mated what a throw
king he ate and then queen c8 and
there's actually a staircase checkmate
oh man
logic through 87's mate mate rookie six
green sevens queen d7 they're three
mates here for white
oh my gosh oh what a huge throw
let's go the punches just love to
realize that he was made in chicago
that's actually a big question
victory charlie's going off the deep end
but frankly
jimmy's got 15 seconds
i hope he doesn't have a flag
c2 and now he hung the house oh it's
done
mate it's not just hanging the rook it's
mate
oh can we cut the truck gotcha can we
get this
close call pikachu no gifted subs
oh okay well that was
far less dramatic that was i mean okay
but next week i mean i don't no point in
looking ahead we've got a crazy day
here today and you know what's hilarious
something just fell from the roof of
this building and hit my camera
i'm gonna scream hi
so the new studio we have here is
actually not complete yet we've been
doing all kinds of stuff
and what you just saw you can't fake um
hey buddy are you gonna don't shake your
head at me like this is on me buddy
i feel so bad but now the rook is
hanging daniel's hanging his rook but
rubio doesn't see it he doesn't have
time oh are we gonna get queenie for
night age four queen eight mate is
ruby's gonna see this oh
ruby's ruby is ruby it's no rubios
the background checkmate levy have i
told you about the g6 phone earlier
i know you were right i didn't know you
were all right
i didn't want to be right my heart is
broken
eclipse can only be a minute long oh
queen c6
let's go leave me a minute come on
rain oh my god oh
oh man
oh my god this is insane
it was jimmy jimmy can't lose on time
okay no stalemate oh my gosh
he just resolved he ran out of time oh
no he resigned
why did he resign you why i literally
just went over real king in game
we're ready we're headed toward mate on
a seven
oh don't open your boy in wisconsin
take the queen and don't look back nico
yeah send this to overtime
whatever oh
and that's why you pay more attention
[Music]
i feel like obviously playing on
oh no the bishop the bishop
no the
a different type of both his gambit
and logic's bishop in the corner the
difference maker
the long-range piece it was hiding it
was hiding on the 80s
oh my god oh my god
no no
no oh
no i
i don't even i don't even damn it
yeah c3 here is very strong i think z35
but
oh knight d5 oh no he blundered
does reigns see it rain is getting low
on time one minute on the clock this is
his last chance it's gonna come down to
the wire
but now king oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
you